this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight up here's Morgan uncensored
trolling with impunity police and big
and big Tech firms are failing the
victims of online death rates I know
that because they just failed me should
social media companies be forced to turn
over the trolls
tens of thousands of ambulance workers
Strikers Britain's winter of discontent
turns deadly I'll talk to a paramedic on
the picket line
plus a top American University is
ridiculed for Banning offensive words
which include wait for this the word
American how do we save our language
from these snowflakes
[Music]
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
I'd like to apologize to anybody
offended by my use of the word
snowflakes uh just struck me that it's
been snowing recently and it might be
offensive to actual snowflake to be
compared to these weak little people
um so my apologies to any genuine
snowflakes offended by the analogy in
comparison to human snowflakes
um again my apologies well good evening
from London welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored imagine a thug approaches you
in the street and threatens to kill you
it would be pretty scary police would
arrest that person hopefully and British
law would say they'd face up to 10 years
in jail and they deserve it no one has
the right to threaten to kill someone
but if that same person makes the same
threat to kill you on social media well
the law apparently can't cope with it in
February last year a troll on my son's
Instagram my oldest son's Instagram made
a very direct threat to my life
You're A Marked Man he wrote calling the
police big Tech or beefing up your
security isn't going to stop us getting
to you this isn't a threat peers it's a
promise you're getting killed now my
first thought obviously was that he'd
misspelled your uh like most digital
morons tend to do but that same troll
then targeted directly my son watch your
back Spencer Morgan if you don't get
your dad and presumably if we don't get
your dad you'll get you're getting it or
your mummies
so direct threat to my son and his
mother in broad daylight
published publicly wasn't a private
message it was a post to an Instagram
photograph that my son had put up that
of me and him now I thought that crossed
a line I don't think you know I'm a big
boy I can take Trolls but somebody
actually going on my son's Instagram
and threatening to kill his father
directly and then threatening him and
his mother no I wasn't going to have it
so I reported it to the police
and the police to be fair well they took
it seriously this is what I said at the
time on my old show about the early
stage of this
you can't guard someone on the street
and say I'm going to kill you I'm
definitely going to kill you because
that is a criminal offense you can do it
on social media so I'm going to do it
for all the people who are getting these
sort of threats and have no recourse to
do it I'm going to push this through
right to the end and I'm going to find
out who did that threat and then they're
going to be held to account and if it
and they'll go to court necessary and I
will appear in court necessary and
that's what we'll keep doing every time
one of these morons thinks that that's
okay because it's not okay
well I've been through the process and
here we are 22 months later and I've got
my answer nothing nothing can be done
London's met police which investigated
his crime for all this time and made an
arrest over a year ago uh told me this
week uh and this was actually from the
CPS ruling which we come back to them
there is clear evidence to prove that
you were the victim of a crime and
threats of a serious nature were
conveyed to you a suspect was arrested
however in order to bring criminal
charges we must first prove that the
messages were sent to you by the suspect
this could not be proved because there
are a number of similar accounts with
the same and similar social media
handles but none which could be directly
attributed to the suspect for the
specific date and time
so that was that a public threat to my
life and to my son's life a 18 to 20
month investigation by the police an
arrest and then nothing because
apparently there are a few similar
accounts on Instagram
now I'm a high profile person this was a
high profile case it made the front page
of the biggest selling newspaper in
Britain so what happens to the millions
of people who are not high profile who
get subjected to vile abuse and death
threats like this every day on social
media
they probably live in a lot more fear
than I do I don't think for a moment
that person actually intended to kill me
I was making a wider point about the
threat
But Ordinary People don't have the
recalls that I do to use the media to
promote this kind of thing they just
have to sit there and hope it doesn't
happen well the owner of Instagram is of
course Facebook uh and now called meta
of course
they posted revenues of almost 120
billion dollars last year these
companies all attack Giants make
planet-sized profits from the data they
harvest on us as we document Our Lives
they know how to show how where we shop
where we eat we work when we travel
often with forensic accuracy the habit
of sell that information to advertise it
so why can't they do more about this
kind of thing which is serious the
police said in the CBS report back to
the police they passed to me but they
acknowledged these were serious threats
and that a crime had been proven to have
been done
but they couldn't do anything so between
Facebook the police and the CPS nobody
could do anything
I think it's time they they did I think
it's time they worked out a way to
handle this not for me I can look after
myself but for everybody else that's
going through this right now probably on
Facebook or Twitter or Instagram or
whatever it may be well joining me now
is the former Scotland Yard detective
Hamish Brown and Imran upman from the
center for countering digital hey
welcome to both of you uh Hamish Brown
you've been a Scotland Yard specialist
uh in in the crime directorate it seemed
to me here that the police came to me
they took it very seriously they
installed a lot of security stuff in my
home they investigated this they got a
suspect they then spent a long time
forensically examining all the
technology this person had in their home
and so on but in the end they didn't
achieve enough evidence for the CPS to
think they get a successful prosecution
I find that so disheartening that such a
blatant death threat published in public
on a social media platform cannot be
enough to actually work out who has done
this yeah well the fact of the matter is
that there are so many people on your
side I mean the police the CPS I have
seen those letters I saw the response by
the CPS and I I'm so sorry it happened
to you I'm sorry it happened to members
of the public who make a very fair point
I was more annoyed from my family to be
honest with you yes I get threats all
the time you know I don't care and
that's fair but yeah and it happens to
the public as well you make the very
good point it's just it's even more
difficult for them because they don't
necessarily have the resources for
protection and security and all the
other when I tweeted about this today
and reveal what had happened
somebody then went on my youngest son
who's 22. they went on his Instagram and
sent him a private message making
another death threat it's utterly
disgraceful but whatever the situation
is and the CPS the whole bright you must
have the evidence now but why can't they
get evidence when someone does that with
such impunity yes well it's obviously
people have access to the same internet
systems without going to technicalities
on it and if we take a parallel off
someone's car being used in a armed
robbery for example
but of course the owner's going to be
seen about that but he said well lots of
people use my car or I lent it out or
something like that the police May well
have their suspicions but it can't be
approved behind Reasonable Doubt and to
be fair for the CPS there's got to be a
realistic chance of a conviction and if
a number of people have same access to
the internet terminals you have alluded
to
that will not convince the court so the
CPS are correct there they're also right
in as much as they they wrote you they
explained the decision I don't know if
you have appealed it or you've got back
to them they invited you to do well I
think it will appear I'm going to get
into review it I think because I'm just
curious about what happens when you
review these things let me bring in uh
Imran Akbar Imran when you specialize in
encountering digital hate what do you
make of my situation here and what
happened
well I mean first of all just to commend
you on bringing forward the issue
because as you said you speak as one
person among many who receives these
threats and you're using your platform
to highlight the issue during the
pandemic I worked with vaccinologists
who were receiving death threats for
tweeting about the vaccines I rece I
worked with
um celebrities who've received death
threats because they're Jewish just last
year we did a study with Rachel Riley
for example we downloaded all of our
Instagram DMS found out how many of them
were vicious vile abuse
um you know disgusting videos death
threats and we we then reported them
back to the platforms and found that now
and out of ten times no action was taken
and there is the nub of the issue that
what we really have is we have the
police and CPS who I know want to do the
right thing by you but the problem is
that the people that hold the
information as to which device was
tweeting from these companies that
gather so much data on us for their own
economic gain we know that they use this
data ruthlessly to Target advertising
they are unwilling to help when it comes
to helping a user who is being who's
been sent death threats and the reason
for that is they don't have to
right that's the problem right because
at the moment so social media platforms
are not held liable for third-party
content on their platforms at all in
particular in the United States under
something called section 230 of the
communications decency act 1996. the
entire reason that ccdh is based in
Washington DC is because there is no way
of getting them to feel any sense of
doing the right thing doing what's moral
doing what's what's helpful for their
users because in reality they don't have
to because they're not liable and so
they think none of my business because
it seems to me that Facebook who own
Instagram
they should have a system they probably
have a system
where this person posts what he did at a
specific time it's all logged they know
what device he posted it from uh they
know all the information they need to
know uh they can presumably have worked
out other stuff he he was posting or
doing from his from his account or other
accounts at the same time shouldn't be
that difficult to hold these people to
account why is this not happening do you
think and what should the law change
be that enforces this kind of thing
so look these are companies that will
sell you the advertise so they will sell
to advertisers the ability to Target
someone who's taking a particular bus
from one side of town to the other by
looking at geolocation data by looking
at what that person's interested in they
will sell every single aspect of your
life and believe me they're tracking you
constantly and yet they won't help when
it comes to solving a serious crime and
the only way to make them feel that it
is kind of their job to deal with it is
to make them in part responsible for
harms on their platforms when they don't
take reasonable steps to deal with them
and that's all we're asking for that at
the moment negligence doesn't really
apply to social media they're the only
companies in the world that don't have
to face negligence right and they don't
think that they don't lose themselves as
Publishers I've had this argument with
them for a long time when I run a
newspaper or when I do television
programs we are heavily regular
regulated and we're deemed to be
Publishers or broadcasters with all the
rules that go with that social media
platforms want to have their their cake
and eat it they want all the benefits of
being Publishers and broadcasters
without any of the liability
well and of course they're infinitely
more profitable than most broadcasters
and Publishers these days in part
because of the fact they're able to
operate with impunity they have a
low-cost model in which they take I mean
they're really parasitic companies
because what they do is they take other
people's content your content news
providers they then aggregate it slap a
bunch of ads on it and then say well
that content's none of my business made
someone else wrote it and of course that
is a fundamentally parasitic business
model now it's a very profitable
business model it's why Mark Zuckerberg
is worth a hundred billion dollars and
he's younger than I am
um but that isn't necessarily a good
business model for society and look
introducing a tiny bit of you know
transparency to these companies some
accountability so if you have a problem
you know who to go to some
responsibilities so they share in the
costs of dealing with the harms created
on their platform that's exactly how
most businesses operate yeah I've Got
Friends I'm not friends who work at high
level at Facebook and they they are
aware of these problems and they tell me
the amount of stuff they have to deal
with is through the roof it's like
millions and millions of things a day
get posted that they remove it's just
they're not doing enough and then when
when these sort of situations happen to
me the system fails people like me are
on the receiving end of it because it
just doesn't work let me bring back
Hamish
um the other problem has struck me about
the police investigation they don't have
time for this kind of thing I mean
they're busy enough as it is and under
resourced enough as it is without having
to chase this kind of thing in the in
the digital sphere what is the answer
for that because they just don't I don't
think they they've got the time to do
this well it isn't just their time and
that didn't the gentleman just now speak
well I mean he put everything in a
nutshell didn't he but the the situation
is and I've done work some confidential
work within the criminal justice system
where the police have been approached to
search someone's emails or mobile phone
or something like that so they can
forensically look at this but they have
warned the organizations I was working
with it's going to take nine months it
might take a year and it's going to cost
us a lot of money that can't be right
now we're not just a small child I
remember my mother saying oh Mrs Smith
down the road got a poison pen letter my
goodness we don't seem to have moved on
from that it's Anonymous and can't trace
it yeah yes to hold the meat to hold the
uh these companies to uh to account
absolutely excellent yeah but because I
just emphasize that the police did
investigate this place they did arrest
the person it has gone to the CPS they
were correct and they hadn't got the
evidence he or the suspect actually did
this that the other and that's what they
must rely on yeah the same with visual
identification or whatever the situation
is so the ball must I think at the
moment it's simply too easy for people
who do this kind of thing to evade
capture and and being held account
that's the problem and we must rest with
the media companies yeah I think that's
where you start certainly hey Miss Brown
uh Imran Ahmed thank you both very much
indeed appreciate it we're coming next
to the health secretary accuses unions
are choosing to inflict harm on patients
as ambulance workers go on strike is he
right I'll debate that with a striking
paramedic and a care home boss you think
they should be not to doing this
[Music]
we're going to come the word American is
offensive apparently according to a top
American University Stanford's published
a blacklist of apparently harmful words
probably includes Blacklist now think
about it and my guest tonight has
promised to use every single one of them
so that should be fun but first unions
in the government are blaming each other
for preventable deaths caused by today's
ambulance strikes more than 25 000
paramedics and emergency call handlers
walked out today over paying conditions
most trust declared critical incidents
well it is the trade unions that are
taking their strike action at a point of
maximum pressure for the NHS and in
doing so or not giving an undertaking to
cover all life-threatening and emergency
responses if people die whose fault is
it tomorrow
absolutely the government's it's been
they've been totally irresponsible you
know the only time they called me in for
a meeting was today the day before the
strike and it's completely irresponsible
of them to refuse to open any kind of
discussions or negotiations with us
so everyone blaming each other uh but of
course the real victims of this are
people who may need emergency help and
don't get it I'm joined Now by a
paramedic at Yorkshire Ambulance Service
Aaron glenwright Cook who's on strike
today and my care home owner David
Crabtree who lost many of the people in
his care home during the pandemic and
has strong views about these strikes and
we'll start with you Aaron glenwright
Cook look you you became a paramedic I
think last year fully qualified one uh
why have you gone on strike
I think there are a number of reasons
it's complex I do think paying
conditions is part of the problem
um ambulance staff of all grades have
had a a real terms loss in earnings over
the last 10 years and it makes it hard
to retain experienced staff that we need
to guide and Mentor younger staff coming
into the service but I think I think
we're all just coming to a place now
where we feel that the emergency medical
system we're working in has collapsed
and we're unable to provide the
emergency care that we're trying to
provide because we're stuck outside of
hospitals that are full and can't
discharge patients back into the
community I mean look you know cars on
the table I think the ambulance service
does a fantastic job in this country
I've had to rely on it several times
myself once when my daughter was very
young and I got unbelievably fast and
exemplary service which I'm incredibly
grateful so let's just park that to one
side I'd bowed to know one of my
admiration for the work that you all do
however and it isn't important however
I just feel very uncomfortable
with notwithstanding what you've just
said about the conditions that you're
working in and presumably already you
believe those conditions are leading to
unnecessary suffering and indeed death
on occasion and that's completely
outrageous and has to be fixed but I
don't see how potentially having other
people die or not getting the emergency
treatment they need helps your cause
because paramedics I think work in a
particular environment a bit like why
the police can't strike where people
rely on you for life and death quite
regularly do you feel comfortable
morally with what you're doing
I think that's a really good question
and one that I very much understand
um I think the thing I've realized today
we spent a lot of time
um obviously on the picket line and
we've spent the last two years being
stuck outside hospitals listening to our
radios go off all day every day open
call open call any ambulance available
to clear for an outstanding Cardiac
Arrest nearest ambulance 28 minutes away
today what we've done is we've said
right we're going to prioritize those
patients the ones that need emergency
immediate life-saving treatment so today
without pay from the picket line we've
still been responding to those patients
that need us most and that need the most
timely response and actually today I
think this is probably the first time in
quite a while and we've been able to
provide that response a good part of our
work is is is actually not immediately
life-threatening care it's
undifferentiated medical problems that
can't be dealt with in the community
because of the lack of resources so I
think whilst it's tempting to think that
ambulances and paramedics fly around to
life-threatening emergencies all day
every day that actually forms about
about 10 or 15 percent of our normal
workload and it's that 10 and 15 that
we've been doing today but you can't be
sure that people won't die
as a result directly of the strike
action can you
people are already dying waiting for
ambulances all day every day
um
very specifically you can't be sure that
some people won't die as a direct result
of the strike action
um I think that's quite a complex thing
to say and that needs a lot of data
points and it will take us some time to
to tease out it depends on how simple
you determine your death to be done
right look in the end self-evident you
can't be certain can you you just can't
no no in the way that I can't be certain
about a great deal of things okay let me
go to uh my other guest uh which is
David Crouch here David we've spoken
before during the pandemic uh some
horrendous stuff that you had to endure
running a care home with so many of your
patients dying what do you make of this
the the paramedics going out on strike
uh good evening I think to just re-end
us what you were saying the paramedics
when they turn up our Care Homes when
they go to the elderly in their own
homes do a fabulous fantastic job
what I don't understand is you signed up
for the job you knew the terms and
conditions and yet you're striking three
days before Christmas
the elderly frail because of the heating
and the fuel and everything they're more
at risk today than they would be in the
middle of June
go back to the social media store why
for I was a shop steward I was a shop
steward for the confederation of Health
Service employees I've stood on the
picket line in the 1980s and yet here we
are 40 years later the government may be
a brick wall but the best advice I was
ever given is if you're trying to go
through a brick wall turn left
the confrontation is achieving nothing
except public will just get dismayed
with it people will lose wages
and my and the the social care
1.4 million social care workers turning
up for minimum wage every day we're
there tonight they'll be there in the
morning they'll be there at the side of
disabled people in their own homes
they'll be assisting people we need
proper social care we need a proper NHS
but this certain striking two days
before Christmas tell me what it's
achieving unless it's a threat to life
well I think listen I think you make a
very good point and the other point I
would make to you I think uh Aaron is
that we have one of the Union reps on
the other night who hadn't even read she
admitted a 2021 report so last year by
the health Foundation which talked about
the reality in particular in a section
of the report uh about ambulance workers
that according to the foundation last
year the average basic pay for ambulance
workers not including overtime increased
over the decade prior to that by 7
588 pounds to 33
487 pounds a rise of 23 in nominal terms
and eight percent in real terms so that
is why there is less sympathy I think
for paramedics at the moment than there
is for the nurses because people think
that actually in the general scheme of
things when it comes to pay you haven't
had it nearly as bad
uh I think what I know for certain is
that the colleagues who work alongside
me in the ambulance my emergency care
assistant and medical technician staff
who work alongside me some of them are
working for around 10 or 11 pounds an
hour and they're having to watch
people's loved ones die they're having
to watch us make end-of-life care
decisions they're having to be exposed
to traumatic cardiac arrest in the
context of road traffic accidents and
they could be making more money and
having a better quality of life
elsewhere and I don't think that's
appropriate recompense for them this
striking is not just about my personal
wages in fact for me actually the wage
rise is not as as big a motivating
factor as my concerns about the overall
But ultimately the point the point I get
all that but ultimately Aaron the point
that David made there I think was a good
one you sign up if you're going to be a
an ambulance worker a paramedic you sign
up specifically to save people's lives I
mean it is that's what the job is
um and you when you sign up you know
what the paying conditions is you may
have not been here you may have issues
of the system we're working in right but
but unlike you know teachers or whatever
you you are in a job where you save
lives and that that's where I have a
problem with this that there has to be a
better way surely to get better paying
conditions than putting people's lives
at risk
I I say in in the same way that you're
saying that I can't be sure that people
wouldn't directly be harmed as a result
of today you also can't be sure that
they will that that lack of sharing but
it's not a gamble I think we should be
taking what I do what you're doing
you're tossing a coin and you're hoping
for the best and I think I I feel very
uneasy about that and I feel very uneasy
by the way about what the public
reaction will be towards paramedics and
ambulance workers if people do start
dying and they blame you I I don't think
you want to be on the receiving end of
that because that's never how you've
been perceived
no I think I think it's important we try
and wake the general public up to the
fact that this is a systemic issue
that's been going on much longer than
today and we are dealing with
unnecessary Death as a result of excess
load and and poor performance from
ambulance trusts as a result of the
system they're working in for years this
isn't new this hasn't just occurred
overnight today and we've been sitting
in queues listening to people who aren't
getting ambulances and are immediately
about to die on our radios for years
that's been going on and that has to
fall at the feet of the people who've
allowed the system to crumble to that
point rather than to individual
clinicians on the picket line today
surely okay David Crabtree just finally
with you I mean
I I understand
what they're saying I understand that
the conditions that they're working in
are increasingly dangerous that they
have to see people dying because choices
have to be made because of the breakdown
of the system can you see their point of
view when it comes to that argument
oh I think they do a tremendous job and
we're not arguing about that what what I
what I'm disturbed at is how why are we
on strike three days before Christmas
why not in the middle of June when the
nights are lighter when people have less
Falls when the elderly are less at risk
why capitalize on winter of discontent
when in fact if you if we want to get
rid of the government if we want to
change things then social media bringing
pressure to Bear we've got all the time
in the world we agree it's collapsed
it's a collapse system the NHS is not
fit for purpose it certainly doesn't
keep the elderly going but the social
care worker tonight on 10 pound an hour
minimum wage is doing the same job
caring for The Elder caring for the
dying assisting feeding moving stopping
pressure areas we're desperate today and
not for anybody to fall we're about to
bring staff into to make sure that
people don't fall because we won't be
able to get an ambulance right
David Crabtree thank you very much Aaron
glenwright Cook I appreciate you coming
I appreciate you spending the time to
talk to me not many wanted to and you
did and I appreciate that thank you very
much
well coming next is the word American
harmful to Americans you might laugh and
think that's a ridiculous question but
that's what Stanford University one of
America's greatest educational centers
has now concluded it's simply too
dangerous to use the word American it's
too triggering well is Tommy lahren my
next guest he triggered by the use of
the word American
I don't think she looks too triggered by
it we'll talk to Tommy after the break
is talk TV
[Music]
well last night Andrew Tay the world's
most infamous influencer blew up the
internet yet again made explosive return
to uncensored last night over a million
people have seen the interview on
YouTube in just 24 hours more on that
shortly we got a reaction what did you
think of it but first administrators at
the prestigious Stanford University in
America have compiled a list of
offensive phrases to eliminate from its
website walk-in is now considered
offensive to be disabled Black Sheep is
banned for its use of the word black and
killing two birds with one stone is
deemed to normalize violence against
animals
wait until they hear about flogging a
dead horse probably on the list actually
but most problematically for the
American University the index of harmful
words includes the word American
I'm actually I'm serious that's not a
joke
they think American is a harmful word
because it implies the U.S is the most
important country in the Americas region
seriously
well the customer your way to alert
sensitive souls to damaging content is
of course a trigger warning
but that's been banned too because the
phrase triggering can cause stress about
what's about to follow so trigger
warnings are now triggering well I'm
joined Now by a a proud American I hope
she could still call herself an American
Fox News contributor Tommy Lowe and
Tommy you are you identifying as an
American or do you feel that it's such a
harmful word now you dare do so
I am a proud American and if I had a
singing voice I would Sing Proud To Be
An American for you that is how proud to
be an American that I truly am I will
never stop saying it and for anybody
that's wondering we do believe in
American exceptionalism here in the
United States of America when we call
ourselves Americans we are proud of that
we are never going to ditch that term
but this is just another example of
especially American universities trying
to out woke one another it is pure
lunacy it is ridiculous you'd think
they'd have better things to do with
their time like maybe educating young
people and educating their students but
apparently picking words that are going
to offend people is a Paramount on there
you see tell me I would say I would
click my fingers and play the the
world's gone nuts this is my my Anthem
have we got that
the world
but unfortunately I think that would
cause more problems because one of the
banned words is insane uh and they
suggest instead using surprising or wild
because the word insane is ableist
language that trivializes the experience
of people living with mental health
conditions so presumably I can't say the
world's gone nuts either because that is
trivializing the world in a mental
health perspective it goes on I mean
some of this stuff is nuts you can't use
Brave because the term perpetuates The
Stereotype of the noble courageous
Savage equating the indigenous male as
being less than a man what and he goes
on user uh you can't use user you've got
to say client because he uses apparently
are only drug addicts they're called
users who can't use it even if you are
actually a user of say software systems
um you can't even use the word Karen
anymore even presumably if you're called
Karen Kanye West yay called me Karen
listen to this
you don't hold accountability to my pain
you're being a Karen I'm talking about
I'm talking about another Karen to the
pain I'm not a cow and I'm not going to
cancel you and I'm not going to answer
you I'm simply going to challenge you on
what you're saying
so I can't be a Karen apparently because
that's offensive too it's almost
impossible Tommy isn't it to say
anything right by this yardstick every
single word potentially is offensive to
somebody
well that's exactly the problem here is
that we're not going to be able to speak
or say anything without offending
someone somewhere at some time over
something that is why this is so utterly
ridiculous and like I said this disease
of wokeness is taking over the U.S I
know that it's largely taking over the
UK as well because we export that to you
I'm sorry I apologize for that as a
proud American but I will say this peers
the cowards are taking over the world
that is what's happening here because we
have allowed the cowards to take over
the world we've allowed them to redefine
terms we've allowed them to have this
snowflake culture infiltrate absolutely
everything that we say and that we do
and now you have to be so sensitive
you're going to call someone the wrong
name you're going to misgender someone
every day it's a new list of things you
can and cannot say but I will tell you
this there's also a little thing called
liberal privilege and it's also leftist
privilege especially here in the United
States of America because liberals can
seem to say whatever they want and they
are allowed to do so they are celebrated
for doing so but if you are a white
American especially if you're a white
American straight male in this country
oh my goodness the list of things that
you cannot do or say is growing you
can't even say Tommy it is absolute
Madness if I was with a group of men and
I said the phrase you guys that is also
now banned by Stanford because you guys
lumps a group of people using masculine
language and or into gender binary
groups which don't include everyone to
which I say shut up you ludicrous waste
rules I want nothing to do with that I
wouldn't mind but I spent the first half
of this show explaining how somebody
made a specific death threat against me
on Instagram and after two years of
police investigation no action is being
taken but if I use the word Karen or say
you guys presumably I now get arrested
by the stand for police
well even worse if you talk about covet
at all you will also be flagged by
Facebook and Instagram and a slew of
other social media platforms this also
goes to show where the priorities of not
only woke universities but the word
police in general lies there are people
around the world that are truly
suffering but instead of focusing on
these people we are sending worthless
virtue signals about how not to call
someone the wrong name you can't even
say woman anymore it's birthing person
and the worst part of it is not just
these woke administrators and
professionals it's also elected
representatives in the United States
that have bought into this they are
perpetuating it and I don't know where
we go from here we're going to start
having to speak in Morse code before too
long because we're not going to be able
to save budget well somebody actually
will have to do this interview by
blinking to you well even that would be
offensive to people of some blinking
disorder
um I I saw on Twitter yesterday Elon
Musk was was asked by somebody which I
thought was quite smart I think he went
to Stanford actually he'd hate all this
but Elon Musk was asked by somebody is
the answer that we all get infested with
degree so much that we all develop
immunity
and then we move on should we all just
inject ourselves with this madness
apologies to Mad people well listen I
don't know if I don't know if the
liberals or the leftists recognize
natural immunity at this point so I'm
not sure that that would be a solution
to this problem but again what it's
going to take is for for liberals and
those on the left to start being
canceled to start feeling like they
can't say and do what they want to say
and do when it comes back on them when
they start to be censored in any way
shape or form that is the only way that
this is going to be reversed it is a
slippery slope luckily I do think most
Americans see through it and find it
quite ridiculous but the problem is if
young people that are going to these
universities that are paying and
hemorrhaging thousands and thousands of
dollars to go to these universities they
are the ones that are being
indoctrinated by this crap and those are
the future generations of Americans and
future generations of human beings and
that is what terrifies me most it is
honestly that I do believe the war on
language is is completely out of control
and the fact that Stanford University is
parties of this is terrifying
um Tommy great to see you I know you're
proud to be an American so we're going
to end this segment with a song May
recognize an Anthem
this is perfect very proud to be
Americans here thank you so much
[Music]
there is a proud American ever I saw one
uh Tommy thank you that was great
well coming next Andrew Tate's
uncensored return last night in divided
opinion blew up the internet as always
is he a Metro Maestro or a misogynistic
Menace we'll debate that next
foreign
[Music]
times so far on YouTube alone his fans
call him a misunderstood Maestro of
masculinity his critics say he's a
malignant malicious misogynist I think
he's probably somewhere between the two
but last night once again he divided
opinion
and I do mean what I say if I were to
see a girl on a private plane on
Instagram for example I would assume
that a man put her on that private plane
I would not assume she bought it herself
well if it was perhaps that makes me
misogynistic what about the Afghan women
it's nothing to do with me on any level
you don't have a view I have a view my
view is that people naturally gravitate
towards Law and Order and if you didn't
have the Taliban you'd have different
Warlords operating in lawlessness and
there would be no way to prevent your
store or your Market stall getting
completely robbed by someone with an
AK-47 and people are going to gravitate
towards a form of Law and Order America
left they left the power vacuum and the
power vacuum is now full what about
their treatment of women only tonight
only tonight they have banned any women
from going to University fantastic let's
get the feminists to go and teach them a
lesson the feminists are so tough and
they stand up and say they can do
anything a man can do let's arm them up
and send them to Afghanistan I'm sure
they'll fix it why can't you just say on
that you know what it's completely wrong
because it's not my point it's I don't
understand it makes me think it'll make
your critics think that you don't think
it's wrong they could ban all men they
could ban all sure then no are there any
Banning movements correct they could ban
all short people they could ban all
people with long hair and not if it's
anything to do with me so they can do
whatever they want I'm not going to go
to war with the Taliban do you think
you're a misogynist absolutely not I'm
not a misogynist on any level this is
one of those buzzwords they throw it and
they just throw at people randomly
homophobic races misogynistics throw it
out at people
what joining me now is talkatively
contribute to Esther kraku and a
trembling broadcaster and journalist
Jenny clean visibly recoiling in Horrors
let's start with you Jenny
um he's not your idea of a role model
well no he's not I I see him as a
symptom of a problem rather than a
solution to it I can understand what's
the problem that he's the symptom the
problem is that I think a lot of young
men uh feel that nobody is speaking up
for them in their culture where we are
encouraged to have identity Politics the
only identity that isn't a good identity
is a young man or a young white male he
talks in a very straight way and he
gives straight answers to uh some
questions which I think he gives very
wrong answers to
um but I find him repellent I think he
he talks about he talks he basically
creates Straw Men that he destroys so he
will uh depict feminism as a particular
kind of thing a kind of man-hating thing
which it isn't well it is for some
feminist for a small number of families
I mean there are some radical feminism
definitely are they definitely are but
most people know that feminism is about
just thinking that everyone should have
equal opportunities regardless of yeah
and one thing we know from Afghanistan
and these heartbreaking scenes today in
Afghanistan of weeping female students
who couldn't go to university and Men
actually in Afghanistan then going out
in protest for them
[Music]
[Music]
I mean really heart-rending scenes
Esther here of these these young women
in Afghanistan weeping because they've
been told they cannot now continue their
education and then you've got male
students walking out in practice very
brave thing to do a bit like we saw in
Iran with the men protesting in support
of the women being oppressed there this
is where he slightly lost me last night
Andrew there are a lot of things he says
which I understand why young men you
feel a bit lost why they gravitate to
his confidence he's very good at
building business he's proven he's made
himself extremely rich doing it a lot of
what he says about masculinity and stuff
I I completely would sign up to actually
yeah and these confidence can help
people but when he was not prepared to
condemn
barbarians for that yeah because that to
me is an open and shut case if you don't
condemn it then I'm afraid you've got a
problem and it's not about sending
feminist in to go to war as I pointed
out what did you think it's a valid
point well a lot of women do actually
fight in the armed forces yeah so I
think
is also nonsense I think he was using
that to kind of attack the more extreme
forms of feminism which that says you
know women can do anything a man can do
and he was using that as an example but
I do think you know you lose people when
you refuse to outright condemn sort of
10th Century barbarians like this
um but I I don't think when you said it
has nothing to do with him I think he's
not willing to get into dicey territory
in that way but it's like you speak in
such absolute terms why do you think
he's a misogynist I don't think he's a
misogynist no I don't think massages
means somebody who hates women I don't
think he hates me I do think he hates
women I think he thinks women are
nothing I think he would not know what
to do with you and I Esther because he
does not know how to deal he gives
interviews to people like you or to Hugo
Rifkin he'll give interviews a lot of
women
he's done interviews with women I've
seen them before on YouTube
yeah and women do a lot of women do like
him exactly there are a lot of women who
don't know him who seem to hate him
ironically but I'm not sure this is
clear because he's a misogynist I don't
think he's a misogynist and I have a
brother who's probably within his Target
demographic 23 and I can understand why
his message would resonate with him
exactly for young men to feel like they
don't have a place in Western society
and he actually makes that point I just
think when you don't want to outright
condemn 10th Century barbarians like the
Taliban you tend to lose your case with
more moderate people but again well not
his Target or the fact that his his
understanding about what's happening in
Afghanistan is that it's a feminist
issue rather than a human issue well no
he did he said send this feminist sin
it's a human issue where we made all
these promises to people in Afghanistan
and then we left well let's be clear we
betrayed those words
in the way we pulled out of Afghanistan
overnight and we betrayed not only
people who work with us the interpreters
and so on millions millions of Afghan
women have just been tossed back to
these barriers who died for it but the
fact that that he sees it he says oh
it's got nothing to do with me as a
human being it should have something to
do and someone who says no I agree I
thought it was a cop out there but
albeit again a lot of what he says I
could imagine if I was a young man it
would resonate with me probably for the
right reasons he's trying to give give
people confidence and a belief that
being masculine is not actually a stick
to beat you with right you can be a good
masculine person it used to be appalled
it
um let's talk to somebody who I don't
think is a shining example of this Joe
likes it who has spent the last month
posturing away with his shiny moral Halo
about David Beckham being in Qatar and
representing the qataris in the world
cup and being paid for it and then the
sun revealed yesterday a rather
uncomfortable truth which is that he had
actually performed himself in Qatar Abu
Dhabi and Dubai in 2015 a series of
stand-up gigs for money Esther now
there's a word for this and I call it
hypocrisy well this is the thing it's
hypocrisy and it's cowardice because he
would say these things but he wouldn't
actually go to Qatar on and sit on
Qatari State television and say all
these things he can sit back comfortably
and rage at the airport his whole point
was David Beckham shouldn't be there and
shouldn't be fronting anything for the
Qatar worries when this guy himself has
taken it and his excuse was so mealy
mouiled Jenny oops I've been caught by
the sun well yes I did two gigs in Doha
actually it was three gigs in Dubai Abu
Dhabi and Qatar I kept it secret by
writing about it in my own book well no
one remembers that from seven years ago
um I was paid a few hundred quid not
keen to say exactly how much not my
Qatar but my UK company promoters who
were being paid by Qatar but it was
2015. when qatar's laws were exactly the
same about homosexuality as they are
today and that went a lot further back
then and so he goes on and then he says
no no but who should I take more
lectures from not from the Sun okay what
about Siri it's not about the sun here
it's about Joe license hypocrisy I think
it doesn't look good for Jay lice it but
I would say that they're different
things the World Cup is about giving
soft power on the global stage
he was like nothing so are gay comedians
going to a country which they profess to
hate
they are basically saying I don't care
I'm pocketing the money it's the same
argument he used against Becca I think
with Beckham it's to do with being an
ambassador on the global stage for a
country that is trying to elevate their
profile Joe lies
Churchill and Bessie Braddock when he
said he was drunk one night he said
Madam would you sleep with me for a
million pounds and she said we should be
for a million pounds well I don't know
Winston and he said uh well would you
send me for a pound no don't be
outrageous well look we already
established what kind of woman do you
think you have we know what kind of
woman you are we're haggling over the
price right that was a joke but my point
about John lices he seems to be saying I
only take a few hundred Beckham took a
few a few million what's the difference
I think you have to be careful about
doing this kind of archeology about what
people have done really quite far in the
past I know it was seven years ago when
it was illegal to be gay in Qatar
in Dubai and it was illegal to be gay in
the U.S once you sanction this kind of
stuff your sanction it's fair game for
anybody like all of those Sports people
who wear it which established when they
were 18 so 10 years ago stop buying it
rank hypocrite don't want us anymore Joe
lice it's moral Halo thanks thank you
Pat good to see you that's it from me
tonight whatever you're up to tonight
keep it unscented good night
[Music]